but the change that's coming
i think is going to be quite drastic and
people are going to be shocked and
people are going to be like wait a
minute what happened
i just could be like yeah well we were
in this really contentious
time for four years where everybody was
on a side
and everybody was fighting and that's
where people derived all the meaning
from life
in the battle all the meaning that
people got out of
life these last four years has been
fighting someone or something
whether they were really fighting them
or not that's the entirety
of the last four years and what i think
is gonna happen now
is that with trump going away sorry guys
i think that that's going to we're still
going to have the fighting to a degree
but it's going to be lessened
dramatically lessened
by circumstances and then
the list eight months coven's been going
on for eight months
covet has reshaped and restructured the
economy in horrible ways
we have whitney webb on to talk about
the people that are trying to use covid
to to
reshape things permanently and whether
they're going to be successful or not
so i'm not discounting that i'm not
saying that that is a
completely improbable conclusion to come
to right
that this is going to have lasting
effects it will like 911.
it's gonna have lasting effect we're
still fighting a fake war on terrorism
kind of
sure even though we're not we are
and kovad will still be around but it's
going to go away
and then when it's done people are going
to go back out
they're going to go back out people are
going to have to go back out and figure
out how they're gonna earn a living how
they're gonna how they're gonna make
money
relationships gonna end coveted
relationships gonna end
friendships are gonna end dude i look at
some of my friends now and i'm like
do i like this person or have we been
quarantined
are we even friends or are we
just reacting to this weird
situation that we're in there are people
in relationships right now
that they know the vaccine means it's
over
they know a vaccine means it over it's
over
i have friends that i know
when a vaccine or whenever hurt immunity
when the cases start
plummeting and people can go back out on
the road again
i have friends i know i'll barely speak
to
and that's okay because i know that this
was a time that meant something that
mattered
it's we all lived through it together we
all got through it
however we got through it but i know
that like
i don't don't make too many decisions
right now
right because when things
end you're gonna want the freedom to
then evaluate things to go
wait a minute this is not the life i
want this is not
these are not the people i want to
surround myself with
you know me and carney were on the road
it was so wild to be on the road doing
stand-up comedy for the first time
in probably five months when i started
stand up
it was september august september of
2010
and i had gone about a decade and i
you know almost 11 years without taking
more than i would say a week off
maybe 10 days maybe and that was once or
twice
i had done stand-up comedy for the
majority of that time for about a decade
i mean all
all the energy that i had in my life was
devoted to doing stand-up comedy
wherever i could and then the quarantine
happened
and also podcasting and sketches or
whatever but and then the quarantine
happened and for the first time
i didn't have something to do on tuesday
night
i didn't have to go to the comedy store
and do a spot and
i had 37 or 40
weekends booked for this year before
i had to cancel my tour because of
corona because they canceled
everything so i was
sitting in an apartment with no stand-up
and no weekends and then this podcast
became my main focus and this podcast
will remain
my main focus even when things open up
because we do a show here that's good
and it's interesting and it's funny
hopefully and
and people enjoy listening to it it'll
always be
my main focus but i also love stand-up
but i love getting out of my house i
love doing stand-up
i love the time you know the shows we
had in west palm and
tampa and dallas and all these places
were great
and nashville and and getting out and
seeing real people
you miss that you miss seeing human
beings not not
after a few weeks doing it you want to
come right back home right
you hope somebody eats another bat you
go lock me down again
newsome lock me down
but you you know i'm kidding you need to
be out there you need to meet people
but you know dana lived in new york he
was a kid pursuing what he wanted to do
doing stand-up going out having fun
dating people
all the new york [ __ ] like i'm a new
york guy you know and then quarantine
happened and he moved back home it was
like this culture shock and like
you know what i mean so me and him then
emerged
and it was like tough because we didn't
we're spending all this time together
and like you barely know how to be
around another human being
because i've only been around you and
you're like a vault of emotion you know
you don't really show emotions
so like when i was with that kid like me
and him like and and it was great we had
a great time and we we worked
out our [ __ ] because it was like you're
in close proximity with another human
being and you you had been in jail
you had just gotten out of jail and now
you're like oh [ __ ]
life is starting again and then it ended
up being great and i think dan's gonna
come out here and move
out here and be more a part of what we
do and i'm happy about that
but this is what i mean i'm using that
as just a little example of like
you know you're gonna get out of jail
folks
you're gonna get out of jail so don't
be too certain
about everything until you're out of
jail and then when you're out of jail
you might
you might say to yourself hey listen
i want to go back to jail which is what
a lot of people do recidivism rate's
very high a lot of people like to go
back to prison
they get out they go you know the
outside's not for me i don't want to
work at
walmart maybe i'll move some maybe i'll
move some weight on the street
let me get into the numbers game a
little bit i learned my lesson i know
how to be a good criminal now i'll be
good at it
but it's going to be interesting to see
how
the world and and and people
that i know you know deal with this
because this has been this has [ __ ]
our heads up
this is [ __ ] everybody i know his head
up everybody i know
their head has been [ __ ] up if your
head has not been [ __ ] up i mean
you're a cold-blooded sociopath and god
bless you i respect that and i admire it
but for most people this thing has
[ __ ] our heads up
not being able to go out see our
friends and our families i mean how many
nice things do i say about my family
every week i am so disheartened
to not be seeing them for christmas and
thanksgiving this year
and also retroactively for the past five
years
but there's going to be a new chapter
coming i think people are scared
of that and i think people are scared of
that because i think so many people
some some people are doing well now i'm
doing good we're doing good the show's
doing good
i hope it keeps doing good i think a lot
of people are not doing good and they're
used to maybe they're used to that
and they're used to being bitter or
cynical or angry or depressed or
whatever
i think people get comfortable wherever
they are and they look at what's going
on around them and they go well this
will always be
there'll always be this external stimuli
there'll always be this
you know noose around my neck but
it's not it's going to be loosened
you're going to be able to go out
you know and i don't mean go out just
physically i mean like
mentally in your head you're going to be
able to live in a world
hopefully without this [ __ ] happening
all the time and i i i think the media
is gonna chill out
i think everyone's gonna show the [ __ ]
out maybe i'm wrong
i can hear people getting so mad at this
episode they're like no it's
no it won't no it's not
you don't know dude it's gonna be like
trust the plan
you don't know it's gonna be like this
forever and ever
because you like it that's the thing you
like it
that's why you don't want to envision
another way you've gotten so used to
this
you like sitting on your couch and
hating donald trump
it gives you something to do or
loving donald trump it gives you
something to do
it gives your life a sense of purpose to
sit there
and be on a team and root for a team and
root against another team
this is what gives you a sense of uh
identity
and unfortunately i think that's gonna
go away and you're gonna have to do
something else like i don't know
scrabble
scrapbooking
so many great scrapbooks got [ __ ] up
by trump like so many middle-aged women
who would have just been really good
scrapbookers
it got [ __ ] up by trump they just had
to sit there and drink wine and curse to
tv for four years
there would have been some really cool
family photo albums being made
instead i have ants on on facebook
talking about q and on instead of
doing what they should be doing like
kicking ass in the kitchen
and scrapbooking ladies
so how's about we get back to that
let's get off read it let's stop with
the pretend you're hunting pedophiles
and
everybody's going to guantanamo bay and
then jesus is going to come down and
cancel your student loan debt and
you know going to take you to sonic one
last time
before you ascend let's cut all that
[ __ ] out
it's not it's not gonna happen move the
[ __ ] on
life is not supposed to be the same
goddamn
thing forever and the last four years
have
felt like forever the last eight months
have felt like forever
we're in a lockdown again nancy pelosi
is somehow
at 99 years old again
the speaker of the house again
they never leave hillary clinton's in
the news again this week like none of
them ever stop
none of them ever go away it's boring i
want to leave the country rogan went to
austin i want to get out of the country
truly i want to get out of the [ __ ]
country we did a deep covered clean on
the house
i'm moving out of palm springs we're
getting out of here i'm out of the
desert
i'm moving because i believe in moving
all the time
i'm moving into the valley in l.a i'm
going to stay there for a while we'll
see what the [ __ ] happens
maybe in a year i go to texas maybe i go
[ __ ] it i want to go to florida go to
texas go wherever i don't care
you got to keep moving it keeps you
alive
you know like that's what
that's what you need in life and i feel
like the aversion to it you know that
dinner i had the other night where
everybody's like oh trump's not going
anywhere and
nothing's gonna change i'm like dude
it's all gonna change
everybody going to college no one's
going to be friends anymore
or you will but it'll be different
trump will be around but it'll be
different he'll say something and
everybody go yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah he'll do the media he'll
do the round of interviews
i mean don't worry about it you're not
gonna you're not gonna have to go cold
turkey on trump
i don't think he's disappearing tomorrow
you're not gonna have to do cold turkey
you'll take your suboxone there'll be a
phase out
it'll be a gradual step down process but
i guarantee you a year from now
you know somehow trump's still in office
a year from now
still covered going on people are
sending me chunks of this episode
like hey smart ass remember what you
said
i'm like well i was wrong but i do
believe
that people are just gonna have to
accept that
a phase is coming to an end here and
then a new phase is going to begin it
could be worse could be better i don't
know what the [ __ ] going to happen